[Music]
okay everyone i'm really really excited
today because
i am joined by georgia king you know
from wild child the new normal vice
principles and most
recently royalties and now she is in
a new film parallel that comes out today
and she plays the character of lena
georgia how are you doing today
hi i'm doing so well how are you i'm
doing really good so
you know i watched this film a couple
days ago i was really excited to talk to
you
about it and what's interesting to me is
that
you are someone i'm so used to always
being in comedies and i really enjoy
your comedic performances
and i was excited to watch this because
when i saw you were in it it was more of
a
serious role can you kind of get me into
like the pros and cons if you can
compare of like doing a serious role
compared to
where you're mostly usually doing comedy
roles yeah
absolutely i mean to start off with i
actually
never anticipated i would be doing a lot
of comedy i didn't realize that's where
i would land and that would be
my very very happy place so when i first
started acting i
i actually ended up doing like you know
i was in england so i did
a series of period dramas of course
um i put on a lot of bonnets and um it
was amazing i loved it
and so i actually came from a more
dramatic sort of
start and then i auditioned for a movie
the movie you just mentioned wild child
and i i got it and it was
the lead villain i suppose and
also my first comedy and that's when i
really got
hooked through acting that's when i was
like oh i need to i need to do this
for as long as i possibly can because i
i had um
i've started acting in my gap year
before and i was going to go to
university i wanted to be a director i
still do
and i'm sort of starting to make my
moves into directing now
um finally but yeah so so acting was
this incredible kind of
unexpected gift and um that i got and
then i
you know i was having such a great time
but then i got like really addicted with
comedy
that being said i think what i i love so
much about comedy is the fact that it's
about
the sort of awfulness and awkwardness
and
realness and messiness of being a human
being
my favorite comedy comes from the the
very subreal and truthful
part of being a human being so like
during the pandemic i've been blasting
my way
through the larry sanders show oh i love
it
which i think is a masterpiece yeah i've
never seen it and i'm like oh this is
this is groundbreaking and it you know
was made
like when i was a child i think and it's
so ahead of its time
um and and what's so special about it is
it it's all rooted in reality
it comes from a place of truth and it's
about real people and real situations
and it has something real to say so
like i said i'm definitely like my
happiest when i'm doing comedy
because it comes from hopefully
something real um
and truthful i i it's a kind of an easy
step into the more dramatic worlds and
if anything i
i hope to bring a little light and humor
into those roles if if it's required
which i felt like it was with this
character lena a little bit
absolutely you definitely do a great
blend of that in bringing a lot of comic
relief into it as well
and i wonder with you georgia when you
look at scripts
what exactly are you kind of hinting
towards it about looking for something
that speaks to you or is more real
what in scripts attracts you to want to
do the role what was it this particular
in this that was like okay i want to i
want to be in this film
oh that's actually quite an easy answer
for this one because
i think i'm fascinated by what we are
hiding and what we're trying to show the
world you know it's like this really
interesting thing that people do
um you know we all want to like you know
fear our best selves and
you know we try and hide our
insecurities and our sort of
self-doubts and i think lena does that a
lot
in this movie you know she's desperate
to be seen
to be valued to feel valuable
and worth something and um and she's
deeply insecure
and so this incredible adventure
starts off with an opportunity to find
that sort of
sense of self-worth and then it unravels
from there so i found i
found the the sort of multifaceted
like layers of all the characters in
this film really interesting
um and i i just wanted to know what was
going to happen next you know
yeah absolutely you kind of yeah you
know them you see them you relate to
them you know they're underdogs they're
on trip and yours you're like
really struggling and then they get this
like
kind of golden ticket moment and it's
like you know i felt when i was doing i
was like oh my god what would i do with
that with that
how would i react in that situation
myself
and i always find that really fun when
it's that immersive well that's really
funny you say that because one of the
questions i have here
i really wanted to ask you is if you
were if georgia was given the chance
in front of a magic mirror would you go
through it would you try it
and what if you did what do you expect
parallel universe georgia would be doing
if you saw her oh my gosh
so it's so funny i actually had a
conversation with mark o'brien who's
lost in the movie and he was like
i would not go through the mirror no i
have everything i want here
and that's like i i have everything i
want here too
but i do find it would be so curious i'd
be so curious just have a little step in
there
and i think i would quite honestly um
i would probably without doing any
spoilers but like you know we find this
mirror
in a space in a house and when you step
through into parallel universes you're
still
in that same room in parallel universes
i would probably hunker down and just
i never feel like i have enough time to
do all the things i want to do every day
like i'm so excited to do so much i want
to like
learn the piano read all these books
like you know
learn how to cook this thing and do that
thing and i've there's so many things
that i want to do in life
i would honestly take the time by
stepping into crowded universes and like
buy myself some time to do all these
cool things obviously
might be boring but i just want to like
i'd use it to my advantage but not
step out of that ethic room no you're
yeah that's a great answer it's just a
smart answer i love it and
it's funny too because like again to
georgia without like spoiling anything
but
a character in this film says to your
character at some point because you see
a lot of crazy things happen because
clearly it's a multiverse film right um
someone says to you i've confessed love
to 10 different versions of you i love
this line but i was wondering
if someone said that to you in real life
georgia would that be attractive to you
or that be a complete turn off
you know it's funny this year i feel
like i've really learned the power of
the word and
you know like something can be like
absolutely like
and skin callingly creepy and kind of
flattering at the same time
maybe maybe both no i i dig that and
it's interesting too because you talk
about comedy and i
i love on your instagram how much humor
you show as a person
and it's really interesting because you
you what blows me away honestly is that
it's like i love your relationship with
your dog rita cause i also have a dog
i'm very close with and
i was scrolling through even today i was
just like oh my god like you have
multiple fans that have
made art of you and your dog that's how
much it's actually like affecting people
so
i'm wondering will we ever get maybe
like a show with your daily like doings
with your dog or like what
behind the scene of georgia king oh my
gosh can i
steal that idea from another parallel
universe yeah you can you don't we can
act like this didn't happen
yeah if i thought that would be in any
way interesting to anyone else but
myself i would do that in a heartbeat um
i
first of all the the fan art of myself
and my dog is
it honestly makes me so happy like i i
like beam
smiling like i just i think it's the
coolest thing it's so
wonderful that people take the time to
do that and um
i do find you know you write what you
know and i as i mentioned earlier like i
want i
set out wanting to be a director and
then i started sidestepping into
into that so i wrote you know i've
written a couple things and i directed a
couple of things and
i'm actually lined up to do i was meant
to do a music video i was meant to be
directing a music video
today um but we had to push the shoot
for obvious reasons
and stuff you know health and safety but
i have a feature next year that i'm
directing and
i end up writing a lot of probably too
many rita references so there's a golden
doodle
there's a lot about a golden duel in a
short film i made
back in 2013 called your hands with
lemon morris and
nicholas braun who's you know amazing
they're both amazing uh michael
hitchcock who's just like
a comedy hero of mine um and yeah i talk
about how i want to get a golden doodle
oh i love that and then i yeah i went
and got one
no that's amazing and like she makes her
way into my life
no and that's smart that like with your
writing because i yeah i love that you
direct and write as well and
you even mention how much like you you
put even in your instability acting and
writing and how much it just shows it
means to you and
i wonder with your talking about just
writing and directing this feature
and this music video how challenging it
is is it during
quarantine to like keep your chops up
with acting writing directing like
is it affecting you in a way like how
can you just kind of give me
an insight into that yeah sure i mean i
had stopped filming something in new
york it was like right when tom hanks
and rita wilson
said you know announced that they had
covered i felt like that's like that day
i think or like an hour later i felt
like we had our
stay at home orders in l.a um so i
really like marry those two things
together like i remember everyone going
to girlfriends and
trader joe's and ralph's and everything
buying all the bananas they could
um in toilet paper and then so i had to
stop filming but um
you know it's funny i i it's that and
again it's like it's been
you know it's been a really challenging
year for everyone and i definitely
you know i'm longing to get back on set
and i know that some production is
starting up again so like
from an action point of view yeah i miss
like i would do like a monthly show at
ucb
um and you know i definitely miss that
like collaboration and onset
energy and i also feel really lucky that
i
you know have a you know a lovely home
and i get to spend this time
working at my writing and getting
hopefully a lot better
um and i've been actually writing
something with mark o'brien um and
um oh my gosh by the way i know i'm so
excited for a now directing
a movie right this second in london i'm
just so impressed
and you know um but yeah i just i feel
like
you know i feel lucky that i get to
also sort of like stop doing other
things always wanted to do voiceover
work
and i started on my first voiceover job
and
i mean no everyone is jumping on the
podcast wagon but i have a podcast that
i'm going to be
putting out into the ether next early
next year and so i've just kind of
i've actually felt like you know i've
taken the
opportunity to work at certain things
that i can do from home and
feel very lucky like that i can do that
no that's really exciting that's
exciting to hear that you're doing a
podcast too i
i can't wait to check it out myself
georgia before i let you go
i have one last question uh it's the
people's question because everyone's
talking about after they saw this movie
and just wondering
and you don't have to answer this but
there is a tree tattoo that appears on
your back
if i'm if i'm seeing correctly and i'm
just wondering
is it did they put that on you during
the movie because i'm looking for
symbolism here or
is that really a tattoo you have and
again you don't have to reveal this
mystery but
if you can the people would love it i
will reveal it gladly
i'm too much of a worse to have gotten a
tattoo that is
100 percent fake oh okay okay i'm really
glad you asked though because
it it does actually lead me into saying
that isaac has done the directions one
of the
absolute best parts of this project for
me the director is
the definition of enthusiasm and energy
and just a shining beautiful person and
had such a strong vision from the start
like i actually watched
one of his movies the incident and was
like oh i want to do this film i want to
work with his director he has a point of
view he has something to say
and him like this very very
unique strong voice like him with you
know taking this script i'm so excited
to see what he does
with it and so he had this vision of a
tree
and a tree painting he had all these
like spiraling camera the camera
movement that he had in his mind
and his imagination was so vivid um
the tree idea was you know there from
the get-go
i love that that just shows you the
attention that i could sing
isaac's phrases yeah yeah that's that's
amazing
i'm glad you picked up on it no i'm
looking for it all you know and that one
stumped me but now i'm excited that
my intuition was correct that it meant
something so georgia thank you so much
for
joining me today everyone if you're a
fan of georgia king what are you doing
you got to see this movie parallel it's
in theaters now and it's also on demand
and you can also check out my interview
with mark o'brien
talking about this film as well that
will be linked below
and like georgia said she's coming out
with a podcast she's directing
she's writing she's doing so many things
and if you haven't seen her in vice
principals or royalties please check
that out
as well georgia it was so nice talking
to you and i hope to talk to you again
someday soon
oh that was a blast thank you so much
for having me